ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA. OUR QUE
HAN BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM
BURNER **** BATH. BONTA BRO
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP. EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LOW MOAN LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN. MULTI O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RADIUS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SMITH STONE. TEAM VOEPEL
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOULD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
THE CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
TO PLEASE STAND FOR THIS
MORNING'S PRAYER. TODAY'S
PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND
PATIOS TO MINISTER. THE PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. IN TWO WEEKS THE
ASIAN COMMUNITY CENTERS
HONORING OUR CENTENARIANS. IT
IS AMAZING TO CONSIDER WHAT
THEY HAVE LIVED THROUGH. BORN
ONE HUNDRED OR MORE YEARS AGO
EACH ONE OF THEM IS LIKE A
LIVING TIME CAPSULE. WE CAN ASK
THEM QUESTIONS AND THEY BECOME
ARE DIRECTED LEVINE LINKS TO
THE PAST. THEY ONCE KNEW AS
CURRENT EVENTS ARE NOW A PART
OF WORLD HISTORY. WORLD WAR ONE
THEY'RE WEARING TWENTIES THE
GREAT DEPRESSION WAR WAR TO.
OUR CENTENARIANS REMEMBER TIME
WHEN THERE WERE NO PAVE ROADS
AND THEY HAVE LIVED TO SEE THE
ENTIRE NATION PAVE COAST TO
COAST. DURING THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD HUMAN HUMAN FLIGHT
WAS A NOVELTY AND THEY HAVE
LIVE TO CS WALK ON THE MOON.
HOW THE WORLD HAS TRANSFORMED
IN THEIR LIFETIMES THE THINGS
THAT THEIR EYES HAVE SEEN.
WHATEVER DIFFICULTIES LIVE
BROUGHT THEIR WAY. NEVER
ADVERSITIES THEY WERE MADE TO
FACE. THEY SURVIVED AND SOMEHOW
INJURED THEIR LONGEVITY CAN
CERTAINLY BE ATTRIBUTED TO GOOD
GENES GOOD FORTUNE AND GOOD
FAMILY. WE OFTEN HEAR ABOUT
THEIR GENERATIONS PHENOMENAL
WORK ETHIC IN TALKING WITH OUR
SUPER SENIORS IS CLEAR THAT
THEY WORKED HARD WITH THE HOPE
THAT SOME DAY THEIR CHILDREN
AND THEIR GRANDCHILDREN MIGHT
HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO SEEK
A BETTER LIFE. WE THE
GENERATIONS THAT FOLLOW.
INHERIT THE LEGACY OF THEIR
EFFORTS AND SACRIFICES. THEY
WILL ALWAYS REMAIN A PART OF
OUR COLLECTIVE HERITAGE. IF WE
ARE FORTUNATE TO HAVE SUPER
SENIORS IN OUR LIVES. LET US
TRY TO SPEND SOME TIME WITH OUR
LIVING TIME CAPSULES. FOR WE
OWE THEM A DEBT OF GRATITUDE
THAT CAN NEVER BE MEASURED.
NUMBER ONE MEDIUM THIN WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU EVER NOTION.
THAT'S OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AS
HE LEADS US IN THIS MORNING'S
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. AND. IS A LITTLE.
THANK MISTER MAIENSCHEIN YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READ A PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY AUGUST
FIFTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN IT'S
ONLY MINUTE NINE AM ON A
REBEKAH POWER QUE HAN IS
SPEAKER ATTEND THIS IN THE
PRESIDING CHIEF THIRTY DOTSON
WILSON AT THE DESK MISTER
CALDERON MOVES IN MISTER FLORA.
A SECOND THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL WILL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE
. WHAT A MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND WATER
EDUARDO GARCIA TO HAVE GUESTS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE ALLOW SOMETHING MEMBERS
RAMOS CARILLO. MURATSUCHI AND
GONZALES TO SPEAK ON IN GERMAN
IN MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT REAL
SIXTY TWO A THE FONG NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HERE.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ON FRIDAY
AUGUST THIRTIETH. AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE GRAY EIGHT SB TWO
NINETY FIVE ACQUIRE SB THREE
THIRTY SKINNER. SB FIVE THIRTY
RUBIO SB FIVE FORTY TWO STERN
IN SB. SIX FORTY SEVEN
MITCHELL. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER TO THE
FOLLOWING BILLS COMMITTEE. AB
TWELVE NINETY A MULLIN FROM THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS IN
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE SB SIX
OF THE SIX BRADFORD AN ITEM.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT SB THREE FIFTY
SIX AND WIRE. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY TO SEE I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO PRINT A
LETTER IN THE JOURNAL FOR A. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR SALAS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON
. MEMBERS PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I AM REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE I
NEVER TWENTY ONE A. B. THIRTY
THREE LACKEY TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER FORTY EIGHTY FIFTEEN
TWENTY NINE LOW TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE
. MEMBERS THE ABSENCES
IT WILL BE NOTED IN THE JOURNAL.
AND ILLNESSES WILL BE NOTED THE
JOURNAL
. MEMBERS ALSO PURSUED
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I'M ALSO RE REFER IN
THE FALL THE FOLLOWING BILL TO
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY JUDICIARY TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
I'LL AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR I REQUEST TO REMOVE SB
FIVE FIFTY TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY THREE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION
. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. WE'LL BE STARTING WITH
AMENDMENTS THIS MORNING MEMBERS
IF YOU HAVE A MINUTES TO TAKE
UP I ASK YOU TO GO TO YOUR DESK
AND BE PREPARED. TO PRESENT
THOSE TO THE BODY. WE'LL START
WITH ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY NINE.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIVE ONE BY
RUBIO CLICK WHEN IT IS. SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTY ONE WITH THE
MEMONS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO.
THIS WILL GIVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB SEVEN
FIFTY ONE IS A BILL THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THE GROWING HOMELESS
HOMELESS CRISIS IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY BY ESTABLISHING
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY REGIONAL
HOUSING TRUSTS AMENDMENTS TO
DATE MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE BILL AND ADD CO AUTHORS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS WISH TO
BE RECOGNIZED. WILL MOVE TO A
VOICE VOTE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. A OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
MINUTES ADOPTED THE BILL IS HOW
TO PRINT IN BACK ON FILE. MOVIE
THAT ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY THE
CLERK WILL READ SEVERAL THREE
NINETY EIGHT WITH THE MEMONS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THESE FLOOR
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND SIMPLY ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED RAISED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND ADD CO AUTHORS INCLUDING
MYSELF I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVALS. THANK YOU MS REYES
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK. WILL MOVE TO A VOICE
VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE
SAY AYE. ANY OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MINUTES
ARE DOTTED. THE BILL IS OUT TO
PAY AND BACK ON FILE
. SIX NINE.
MEMBERS MOVING DOT FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SIX. THE CLERK ONE IT IS
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY EIGHT
WITH THE MEMONS BY SELLING
MEMBER KALRA. MISTER KALRA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS MAKE
TECHNO ON CLARIFYING MANAGE THE
BILL AND EXTEND THE AMENDMENT
IMPLEMENTATION DEADLINE TO
ALLOW OPPOSED TO PROMULGATE
MODEL POLICIES RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE BILL BE AMENDED.
AND PLACED BACK ON THE FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CARR THE THEIR
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE I ANY
OPPOSED SAY NINE. AYE AYES HAVE
IT. THE MINUTES ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT IN MY BACK
ON FILE. FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT
IS NEXT COOKERY. SENATE BILL
TWO EIGHT WITH THE MOMENTUM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. SHE
GAVE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE TO
PUT DATA PRESENT MINOR
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS SB TEO I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
MEMBERS EITHER TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IT WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THOSE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES HAVE
IT. THE MINUTES ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND WERE
BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ. NOT ON. WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON AYE TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY NINE FILE ITEM NINETY
THE COOKERY SENATE BILL SIX
FORTY FOUR WITH THE MEMONS BY
SOMETHING MEMBER OF OUR CAN'T
MISS BARRICADE HEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AMENDMENTS AND SB. SIX
FORTY FOUR SIMPLY ADD CO
AUTHORS TO THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THAT THEY HAD.
MEMBERS THESE ARE AMENDMENTS
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY. GUYS HAVE IT
DID MANAGE OUR DOCTOR THE BILL
IS OUT TO PRINT AND WE'RE BACK
ON FILE. WILL MOVE THE FILE
ITEM NINETY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY ONE WITH THE
MEMONS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE. IS THERE A
COMMON AB ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I SEE ARE SEEKS TO
HONOR WILLIE L. BROWN JUNIOR BY
NAMING THE PUBLIC STREET CIRCLE
AND PLOWS THAT NINE FOURTEEN
AND NINE FIFTEEN CAPITAL MALL
AS THE WILLIE L. BROWN JUNIOR
CIRCLE AND PLOWS ARE. MISTER
BROWN IS WIDELY REGARDED AS ONE
OF THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
POLITICIANS OF THE LATE
TWENTIETH CENTURY HE HAS BEEN
AT THE CENTER OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AND CIVIC LIFE. FOR
AN ASTOUNDING FOR DECADES. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY MISTER BROWN
MADE HISTORY WHEN HE BECAME THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN SPEAKER
OF THE ASSEMBLY A ROLE HE HELD
FOR RECORD FIFTEEN YEARS.
DURING HIS THIRTY YEAR TENURE
AS AN ELECTED MEMBER OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY MISTER BROWN
LEFT HIS IMPRINT ON EVERY
ASPECT OF PUBLIC POLICY
IMPACTING THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. S. C. R. THIRTY ONE
CELEBRATES THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF MISTER BROWN. AS WELL AS HIS
UNRELENTING DEDICATION TO A
BETTER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. TAKE IT IS COMMONLY THAT.
THIS COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THESE
AMENDMENTS AND HONORING. WILLIE
WAS BROWN JUNIOR I THINK THIS
IS A SENSATIONAL IDEA THAT
LOCATION THAT CIRCLE. IS
UNMISTAKABLY THE SEAT OF
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT.
THE BRIDGE BEHIND THE CAPITAL
IN FRONT THE LIBER COURSE GOING
TO THE SOUTH THE ON REBUILDING
TO THE NORTH NO MORE PRIMITIVE
POINT FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENT. AND AS YOU MAY KNOW
FROM WILLIE BROWN'S BIOGRAPHY
WHEN HE WAS A YOUNG MAN OF
BROWNSVILLE TEXAS. HE HAD A JOB
SHINING SHOES. AND IN THOSE
DAYS THEY STILL USE PLATOONS.
IT WILL IT WAS BROWN JUNIOR WAS
WOOD SHINE SHOES AND PEOPLE
WOULD PUT HIS PAYMENT IN THIS
PLATOON FORCED AND PULLED OUT.
A GREAT MEASURE I SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENT AND THE RIGHT PLACE
TO PUT A- PUT HIM FROM WHERE HE
STARTED IN BROWNSVILLE TEXAS TO
THE CROSSROADS OF CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER COOLEY. MEMBERS THIS ON
THE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THOSE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE MINUTES
ARE ADOPTED. THE BILL IS OUT OF
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE
. ONE
THIRTY NINE. MEMBERS RIGHT FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE ON A
MINUTES COOKERY CYNICAL SIXTY
FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY
MEMBER KALRA. KALRA MISTER
KALRA ON THE MINUTES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THERE MISTER KALRA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. BOTTOM ONE
THIRTY NINE. THANKS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SB SIXTY
FOUR SHOWS THE CURRENT PRIVACY
RELATED SECTION AND IT WAS
COMMUNICATIONS MICROCHIP BUT
ISSUES IN THE RUSSIAN BEYOND
THE UNIFICATION OCCASIONS AS
LONG AS A MAJOR COMPANY
RECEIVED CONSENT REGISTRANT
SELECT YES WHEN I BUT ON THESE
AMENDMENTS WELL DONE THIS CAR
MEMBERS ON THE AMEND ITS WE.
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. THERE
WAS A NAY. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT TO HOW TO PRINT AND
WE'RE BACK. ON FILE. THE BILL
GO TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY NINE.
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
ONE SIXTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK. AS A
MEMBER QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
SO I RISE TO PRESENT SB ONE SIX
SEVEN FOR MANAGEMENT PURPOSES.
THE AMENDMENTS TO DRESS CHAPTER
IN OUT ISSUES AND CLARIFY THAT
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES. MAY
PROVIDE BACKUP ENERGY RESOURCES
FOR VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. IN
ORDER FOR CUSTOMERS WHO RELY ON
LIGHTS LIFE SUPPORT EQUIPMENT
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION THESE
AMENDMENTS AND I ASKED THAT
THEY BE ADOPTED. THE BILL SENT
OUT TO PRINT AND PLACED BACK ON
FILE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER QUIRK. MEMBERS ON THE
AMENDMENTS WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
MINUTES ARE ADOPTED THE BILL IS
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
TO BRING THIS UP FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE FORTY NINE. I'M
SORRY FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY THE
CLERK WILL READ. SYMBOL FOR
THIRTY NINE WITH THE MEMONS BY
SOMETHING MEMBERS MATH. A
SIMILAR SERVICE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDING SB FOUR THIRTY NINE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR UMBERG.
THIS TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
CLARIFIES THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE REGULATIONS REGARDING THE
FORM BUT NOT THE CONTENT OF THE
REPORTS THAT MUST BE FILED BY
ANY AGENCY THE AMENDMENT WAS
DRAFTED WITH THE INPUT OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MET. MEMBERS WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY
AYE. OTHERS POST A NAY. THE
AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FIFTY
TWO. THE CLERK LAURIE SENATE
BILL SEVEN TWENTY SIX WITH A
MOMENT BY SELLING MEMBER QUIRK.
DOT QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE MEMBER TO DRESS CHAPTER NOW
ISSUES IN OUR TECHNICAL IN
NATURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOT
QUIRK. MEMBERS WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY
AYE. A POST SAY NAY. AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS
THAT WERE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE FIFTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY FIVE
WITH THE MEMONS BY SOMETHING
MEMBER QUIRK. SCORE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED CLARIFYING IN NATURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOT QUIRK
APPRECIATE THAT EFFICIENCY
MEMBERS TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THE AMENDMENT ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE. A POST A
DAY. THE AYES HAVE IT IN
MINUTES ARE ADOPTED THE BILL IS
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS RETURNING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY NINE. FOUR
MINUTES THE CLERK WILL BE
CYNICAL TO TWENTY SEVEN WITH
THE MEMONS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SMITH. ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE AMENDMENTS TO SB
TWO TWO SEVEN BEFORE YOU TODAY
OUR TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SMIT MEMBER WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
I ANY OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF
PRINT AND WE'RE BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS TURNING TO OUR GUESTS
INTERJECTIONS THIS MORNING WE
HAVE SOME GUESTS WITH US IN THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MR MULLINS
THAT'S FOR YOUR INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH A GREAT
HONOR TO RECOGNIZE THIS MORNING
AND CELEBRATE THE ROYAL CHICANO
AIRFORCE AND IT'S FIFTY YEARS
OF SERVICE AND ACTIVISM IN OUR
STATE AND NATION. FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE SACRAMENTO
BASED OUR COLLECTIVE IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT ARTISTS
GROUPS TO COME OUT OF THE
CHICANO MOVEMENT. THE ROYAL
CHICANO AIRFORCE WAS FOUNDED BY
THE LATE. SAM ANTALYA AND IS
THERE WILL BE A WHO IS PRESENT
WITH US TODAY TO PROMOTE THE
ARTS EDUCATE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
FOSTER SUPPORT. FOR THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS. ROACH GUN WHERE
FORCED PLAYED AN INTEGRAL ROLE
IN HELPING UNIONIZE FARMWORKERS
AS THE ART COLLECTIVE SHARED A
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP. WITH CESA
CHAVEZ AND THE LOTUS WHERE. AS
A COMMITTED. GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS TO THE FARM WORKER
MOVEMENT THESE MEMBERS HAVE
ALSO BEEN EQUALLY COMMITTED TO
EDUCATION AND THE EMPOWERMENT
OF THE CHICANO COMMUNITY. ROACH
GUNNER FORCE MEMBERS HAVE
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO
EDUCATING AND EMPOWERING THE
NEXT GENERATION. THEY WORKED AS
EDUCATORS IN THE CAGE AND
TWELVE SYSTEM COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY LEVELS WITHIN
JUVENILE AND ADULT. I CAN
FACILITIES AS MUSEUM AND
GALLERY CURATORS AND STATE
ADMINISTRATORS FOR OUR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS HERE. IN
THIS GREAT COMMUNITY OF
SACRAMENTO. EDUCATION IN ART I
HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THE ROLE TO
KIND OF FORCE HAVE UTILIZED TO
ADVANCE ECONOMIC AND
EDUCATIONAL ALONG WITH
POLITICAL EMPOWERMENT ANY
QUALITY. NOW YOU KNOW I ONCE
READ A BOOK IT WAS BY THE GREAT
AMERICAN PLAY WRITER ACTOR AND
FILM DIRECTOR RESPOND THIS IN
THERE'D BEEN SOME MENTAL SET UP
AND DO YOU KNOW WHERE HE SAID.
TO BE CHICANO IS TO LOVE
YOURSELF. YOUR CULTURE YOUR
SKIN. AND YOUR LANGUAGE. AND I
THINK TODAY YOU KNOW WE GET TO
HONOR THIS GREAT. GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE A BODY.
THAT PHILOSOPHY. AND FOR MANY
OF US I THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR
THE MAJORITY OF THE LATINO
LATINO SO WHERE HERE. WHO
PERHAPS IDENTIFIES CHICANO THE
CHICANOS AS WELL. IT IS THIS
TYPE OF WORK. THAT HAS
MOTIVATED US. TO BE HERE IN
STATE CAPITOL AN ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF OUR COMMUNITIES I
JUST OUR DISTRICT BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. SO FOR
ME IT'S A GREAT HONOR AND I
KNOW ON BEHALF OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IT IS TO HAVE YOU
ALL YEAR AND RECOGNIZE FIFTY
YEARS. OF HARD WORK AND
DEDICATION ON BEHALF OF THE
CHICANO COMMUNITY. NOT JUST
HERE SACRAMENTO NOT JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA BEFORE THE ENTIRE
NATION CONGRATULATIONS POLICY
THAT IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY AND I
KNOW YOU'LL BE RECOGNIZED BY
THE STATE SENATE AS WELL SO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA. STATE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA MR MCCARTY YOUR
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU THAT'S-
THANK YOU I WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON OUR- COMMENTS FROM MR
GARCIA. MR GARCIA PAGING MISTER
GARCIA WAIT ONE SECOND I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT THE RCAF IS
OF COURSE KNOWN THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE GLOBE
THEIR POLITICAL ACTIVISM
STARTED RIGHT HERE IN THE
CAPITAL CITY OF SACRAMENTO. OUR
SUPERVISOR HERE FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY MISTER CERNAT TALKS
ABOUT AS A YOUNG BOY REMEMBERS
HIS LATE FATHER ARE MAYOR HERE
JUST ARE NOT OPENING UP THE
GARAGE AND THE SILK SCREENS FOR
PRINTING THESE POSTERS TALKING
ABOUT NOT JUST PART. BUT
EMPOWER ME POLITICAL ACTIVISM
AND STEPPING UP TO THE ISSUES
OF THE DAY IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE IS THAT I WAS TO SEE THAT
SOME OF THE CURRENT INDIVIDUALS
ARE HERE AS WELL AS THE NEXT
GENERATION. SO I THANK YOU FOR
WELCOMING OUR CFF TO THE STATE
CAPITOL AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
FIFTY YEARS. OF EMPOWERMENT IN
OUR CAPITAL CITY AND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA
. MEMBERS. BACK ON
THE FILE WILL GO TO THIRD
READING FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
FOUR. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE TWENTY NINE BY SELLING OVER
BONTA AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
THE LEYTE LANDING COMMEMORATION
DAY. YOUR BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED HER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES TODAY
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT ACR ONE
TWENTY NINE A RESOLUTION THAT
COMMEMORATES OCTOBER TWENTIETH
AS LAKE TATE LANDING IN
COMMEMORATION DAY. SEVENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO THE LEYTE LANDING LED
BY GENERAL DOUGLAS MCARTHUR
COMMENCED THE LIBERATION OF THE
PHILIPPINES FROM JAPAN. THIS
DECISIVE BATTLE CULMINATED IN
ENDING ALMOST THREE YEARS OF
JAPANESE OCCUPATION AND
REESTABLISHED THE COMMONWEALTH
GOVERNMENT OF THE PHILIPPINES.
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THE PROUD
HOME OF MORE THAN ONE POINT SIX
MILLION FILIPINO AMERICANS
MAKING CALIFORNIA THE STATE
WITH THE LARGEST PERCENTAGE OF
FILIPINO AMERICANS IN THE
NATION WE MUST NOT FORGET THE
MONUMENTAL HISTORICAL IMPACT OF
THE LATEST LANDING. ESPECIALLY
SINCE IT IS INEXTRICABLY LINKED
TO THE HISTORY AND LINEAGE OF
SO MANY CALIFORNIANS AS WE
RECOGNIZE THE SEVENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE LATE A
LANDING LET'S PASSED THIS
LEGACY FORWARD AN HONOR ALL OF
OUR FILIPINO AMERICAN MILITARY
VETERANS AS WELL AS THE
FILIPINO AMERICAN COMMUNITY. IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE UNITED
STATES AS A WHOLE MEMBERS I ASK
YOU JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING ACR
ONE TWENTY NINE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER BONTA ARE YOU
SEEKING CO AUTHORS ON THIS
RESOLUTION. I AM YES THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER VERY GOOD.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK. THE ROLE CLICK TO
OPEN OF ALL FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS A VOTE FOR CO
AUTHOR IN. THE CITY THE
CONCURRENT ACR BY MR BONTA. ALL
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH
TO ADD THEIR NAMES A CO AUTHOR.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES
HAVE IT. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MR BONTA YOU HAVE SOME
GUEST NEED IDENTITIES. I DO
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU
MEMBERS ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS OF THE ALPHA RADO
PROJECT THE ELDORADO PROJECTS
SEEKS TO FOSTER MULTI CULTURAL
UNDERSTANDING AND COLLECT
HISTORICALLY SIGNIFICANT
ARTIFACTS AND MATERIAL ABOUT
THE FILIPINO AMERICAN COMMUNITY
THEIR CHAMPIONS WITHIN THE
FILIPINO AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
TRAVEL HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
OUR LATE DAY. LANDING MEASURE
THANK YOU OF ROGER OUR OUR
PROJECT AND WELCOME. THANK YOU
MISTER BONTA. MOVING DOWN THE
DAILY FILE MEMBERS WILL GO TO
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ. A SO MAKING A
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY BY FAMILY
MEMBER WEBER AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO AFRICAN DESCENDANTS
OF SLAVES IN THE UNITED STATES.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
TO YOU ACR ONE THIRTY. AUGUST
TWENTY. NINETEEN MARKS THE FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS SINCE THE FIRST
AFRICAN CHAO'S SLADE WAS
BROUGHT BY SHIP TO VIRGINIA.
THE FIRST OF MANY VOYAGES
BETWEEN SIXTEEN NINETEEN IN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE ABOUT FOUR
MILLION AFRICANS TO BE ENSLAVED
IN THE UNITED STATES. IT SHOULD
BE NOTED HOWEVER THAT THIS WAS
NOT THE FIRST TIME AFRICANS
CAME TO THE NEW WORLD. IN FACT
AT THE I HAVEN'T BEEN SORT OF
WAS WHAT THEY CAME BEFORE
COLUMBUS DOCUMENTS THAT MAKE
YOU SICK THE CIRCUMVENTING THE
WORLD AND LANDING IN THE
AMERICAS. WE ALWAYS THINK OF
CALIFORNIA AS AN EXCEPTION TO
THE EVILS OF AFRICAN SLAVERY.
WHAT CALIFORNIA ENTERED THE
UNION IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY AS A
FREE STATE WAS LABOR WAS
NOMINALLY ILLEGAL AND SIDED
WITH AND SIDE WITH THE UNION
DURING THE CIVIL WAR. THERE
WERE ABOUT TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
BLACKS LAYS IN THE STATE BY
EIGHTEEN FIFTY TWO. MANY
BROUGHT BY SOUTHERNERS WHO WERE
LOWER TO CALIFORNIA BY THE GOLD
RUSH. IN THE EARLY EIGHTEEN
FIFTIES THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE AND THE JUDICIARY
CONSTRUCTED A WEBER STATUTES
AND LEGAL RULINGS THAT UNDERCUT
IN SLAVE. PEOPLE'S CLAIM TO
FREEDOM AND COMMITTED THE STATE
GOVERNMENT TO COMPELLING SLATE
WILL BE THE ANSWER WE HAVE A
FUGITIVE SLAVES TO RETURN TO
THEIR OWNERS. THE COP YOU LET
YOUR FOUGHT. FREE BLACKS FROM
IMMIGRATING OR LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNMENT PERPETUATED CONDONED
AND PROFITED FROM PRACTICES
THAT BRUTALIZE AND
DISADVANTAGED AFRICANS IN
AMERICA AND THEIR DESCENDANTS
INCLUDING SHARECROPPING CONVICT
CONVICT LEASING JIM CROW LAWS
READ READ READ LINING UNEQUAL
EDUCATION AND THE
DISPROPORTIONATE. TREATMENT AT
THE HANDS OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN A MISSISSIPPI OR
ALABAMA BUT OUR LAWS AND
INSTITUTIONS NONE THE LESS.
ENABLE CHATTEL SLAVERY HERE AND
CONTRIBUTED TO THE LONG TERM
LONG AFFECT OF SLAVERY ON THE
DESCENDANTS OF BLACK SLAVES TO
IT TO THIS DAY. OUR ANCESTORS
WERE BROUGHT HERE INVOLUNTARILY
TO PROVIDE FREE LABOR. BUT EVEN
LONG AFTER EMANCIPATION
CALIFORNIA LAWS CUSTOMS AND
POLITICAL IDEOLOGIES WORKED AND
STILL WORK. TO IMPEDE OUR FULL
INTEGRATION TO THE ECONOMIC
LEGAL AND POLITICAL LIFE OF THE
STATE. THE FACTS ARE THAT
BLACKS ARE STILL UNDERPAID.
UNDEREMPLOYED UNDER EDUCATED
OVER POLICED AN OVER
REPRESENTED IN PRISONS AND
JAILS. I BRING THIS RESOLUTION
FOR BECAUSE IT IS NECESSARY TO
HAVE AN OPEN DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHAT PRACTICAL STEPS WE NEED TO
IMPLEMENT. REPARATIONS
REPARATIONS IS NOT A HAND OUT.
REPARATIONS ABOUT ACKNOWLEDGING
THE GREAT WRONG CALIFORNIAN
GAYS IN BY ENABLING ILLEGAL
SLAVERY TO CONTINUE IN THE
STATE. FOR REFUSING TO PROVIDE
ASYLUM FOR FUGITIVE SLAVES BUT
PASSING LAWS THAT WILL PREVENT
FREED SLAVES OF LIVING HERE.
AND FOR PASSING LAWS THAT
PERPETUATED THE INJUSTICES OF
SLAVERY AFTER HAD BEEN
ABOLISHED. THIS TOPIC HAS LONG
BEEN STUDIED EXTENSIVELY AND
CLEAR RENOUNCING SLAVIN
INEQUALITY IS NO LONGER
SUFFICIENT. ACTION IS REQUIRED
TO RECORD BEEN WRECKED RECTIFY
THIS INJUSTICE. REPARATIONS ARE
PRACTICAL REMEDY FOR THE ACUTE
ECONOMIC LEGAL POLITICAL
EDUCATIONAL INJUSTICES
RESULTING FROM SLAVERY WELL
EXPERIENCED BY BLACK
DESCENDANTS OF SLAVES TO THIS
DAY. THIS BILL IS A PRIORITY
BILL AND IS SUPPORTED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE. BLACK CAUCUS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM DOCTOR
WEBER YOU SEEKING CO AUTHORS
FOR THIS RESOLUTION MEMBERS DR
WEBER IS ASKING FOR CO AUTHORS
OF THIS RESOLUTION THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
ONE THIRTY. THE CLERK THE CLOSE
OF ALL THERE ARE FIFTY SIX CO
AUTHORS. WE'LL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS ITEM MEMBERS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED
. MEMBERS WERE MOVING
THE CONCURRENCE. TAKING UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT. THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY WILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC CONTRACTS HIS DARK HAIR
AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
PRESENTING AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH IS BACK STAND
CONCURRENCE THE BILL WOULD
ALLOW REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES. TO UTILIZE THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER GENERAL
CONTRACTOR OR C. M. G. C.
PROCUREMENT PROCESS FOR OFF
HIGHWAY CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE WERE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE AND THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. TAKING HIS PARA QUE HAN
SIDO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES THE EYES
SEVENTY ONE KNOWS ZERO. AND THE.
AND THEN IT'S OUR CONCURRED
WITH
. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY AB EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ AS A
LEGAL EIGHT TWENTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER MULLIN AND OTHERS AND
THAT CLING TO THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY FLOOD IN SEA LEVEL RISE
RESILIENCY DISTRICT MR MILLING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY FIVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE DISTRICT BILL THAT
WOULD MODIFY SAN MATTEO
COUNTIES EXISTING FLOOD CONTROL
DISTRICT INCREASE THE FLOOD IN
SEA LEVEL RISE RESILIENCY
AGENCY SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL. AND REFLECT INPUT
FROM THE LANDS COMMISSION ASK
FOR NAY VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MIND SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE IT. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
WILL PASS THE RETAINER FILE
ITEM ONE FILE ITEM TO AB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA
AND EXPLAINING MEDI CAL. MR
FLOOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT IS BACK AND ENCOURAGE AND
SENATE THE AMENDMENT TO DELETE
THE SECTION A BILL THAT WAS
RECENTLY ENACTED THROUGH THE
BUDGET RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK
YOU MISTER FLORA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I SIXTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THE PAST THIRTEEN ON FILE
ITEM. THREE FILE ITEM FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVENTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY NINE MY FAMILY
MEMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALING ARTS MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BEEN A SECURE MEMBERS AB SEVEN
SEVEN NUYS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
FILE ITEM FIVE WE'RE NOT
PASSING CHAMBER TAKING UP FILE
ITEM FIVE AB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR
THE CLERK WILL READ THAT'S ONLY
BILL LEVIN SIXTY FOUR BY SOME
REMEMBER GLORIA AND ACTUALLY TO
STATE REAL PROPERTY MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE SIR
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENT SENATE MINUTES OUR
TECHNICAL INQUIRE FIND IN
NATURE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
GLORIA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THERE ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
PASSING RETAIN AND FILE ITEM
SIX FILE ITEM SEVEN AB THIRTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY FOUR BY
SOMETHING MEMBER ON THIS AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY PEOPLE'S
CERAMICS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
THIRTY FOURS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE. THE
SENTIMENTS MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO THE BILL TIGHTENING
THE REQUIRED RESOURCES WE
PROVIDE ON THE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES LANDING PAGE THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES. LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER ROBERTS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY AND VIOLATED MEET.
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
NINE FILE ITEM TEN EIGHTY TWO
SIXTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIXTY SEVEN
FIVE FAMILY MEMBER KANSEN CHU
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MARIN SPEAKERS AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO OF PERCENT
AB TWO SIXTY SEVEN A BILL PUSH
EXTENT HEALTH PROTECTION FOR
BABIES WORKING IN TELEVISION
AND MOVIES. TWO BABIES WORKING
IN ALL FORMS OF ENTERTAINMENT
THE SENATE THERE MA'AM AND OUR
TECHNICAL AND CLEVER FIRING
THIS WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANKYOU MISTER CHIU SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO THE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM ELEVEN
AB FOR TWELVE THE CLERK WILL
READ. A SOME LEGAL FOR TWELVE
BY SOME REMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
ESCROW AGENTS THIS QUIRK SILVA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER REMEMBERS AB FOR
TWELVE IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
THIS BILL BILL IS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER EXCEL AS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY BY
SOME REMEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE BEES MR
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FOR
FIFTY IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AB FOR FIFTY REQUIRES AN APIARY
OWNER WHO RELOCATES ARE
REGISTERED APIARY WITH IN A
COUNTY TO A LOCATION THAT THEY
NOTICE TO THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSION WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS SENATE AMENDMENTS OUR
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING AND I
ASK FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE. IN
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
FORTY EIGHTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT BASED ON THE
NUMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS
AND EXPLAIN TO COMMUNICATIONS
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT AT THE
STATE LIBRARIAN AND THE
GOVERNOR'S TRIBAL ADVISER. THE
CALIFORNIA BROADBAND COUNCIL
THESE CHANGES REFLECT FEEDBACK
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AND
WILL ENSURE THAT THE NEEDS OF
RURAL AGRICULTURAL TRIBAL IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE
CONSIDERED IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF STRATEGIES TO EXPAND
BROADBAND ACCESS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I WROTE. YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACKLAND COMMUNICATIONS CUTTING
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SO SANTIAGO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I THINK YOU
MEANT SPEAKER THIS BILL BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE AFTER EXCEPT
THE NON TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRED VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB SIX
FORTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
AS A LEGAL SIX FORTY FIVE BY
SELLING MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY TO BUY ARMS IS OR WHEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB SIX FOUR FIVE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE POSTING OF
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE. NUMBER ON EXISTING
LABELS OF GUN PACKAGING ON
FIREARM SAFETY CERTIFICATION
EXAM AND ON NEW SIGNS AND GUN
SHOP SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
THAT AN EXISTING SUICIDE
PREVENTION PROGRAM CAN PROVIDE
A NEW SIGN THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE THOSE IN HERE MISTER
WHEN SEEING. AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE ICE FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
FIVE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY FAMILY
MEMBER EGGMAN AND ACTUALLY TO
AGRICULTURE MAKING PREPARATION
THEREFORE. SECOND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS A. B. SIX FIFTY SEVEN
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE TO
CURRENT AMENDMENTS HAVING TO DO
WITH FEED AND ITS TONNAGE FEES.
INDUSTRY SPONSORED THOSE WHO
ARE PAYING THE FEE ARE ASKING
FOR THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU MISS
EGGMAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NEWS ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AB EIGHT HUNDRED THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT HUNDRED BY SOMETHING
MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE SELECTIONS. MR
TO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHT HUNDRED
IS A BILL WHICH WILL ALLOW
PARTICIPANTS IN THE SECRETARY
OF THE STATE SAFE AT HOME
PROGRAM TO FILE WILL COURT
DOCUMENTS AS JANE OR JOHN DOE.
THE DATE MAJORITY OF THE SENATE
THERE MA'AM AND OUR TECHNICAL
INTO YOUR TO CHANGES TAKEN TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION ONE WERE ALLOWED TO
CORD DISCRETION TO USE THE NAME
ALL THREE PARTIES WHEN THEY
DEEM NECESSARY WAS THE SAFETY
OFF THE PARTICIPANT IN MINE.
THE SECOND MAKE SURE THAT
DEPEND THE MINERS RIGHT OR
PROTECTED BY REQUIRING NOTICE
TO THE MINORS SOCIAL WORKERS OR
PROBATION OFFICERS OFTEN MINERS
PARTICIPATION IN AN ACTION DOES
FOR RICK HAVE NO VOTE CAST
AGAINST IT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR- BIBLE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHIU SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL. OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLAIRE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND
FILE ITEMS TWENTY ONE THREE
TWENTY THREE FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY NINE TO THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE OH
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
AND ACTUALLY THE LITTLE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. THROUGH
LIVING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AB
NINE OH TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
LEVINE SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY NINE TWELVE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWELVE BY SELLING MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE MARINE INVASIVE
SPECIES. WITH THE MESSAGE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I'M PRESENTING AB NINE
TWELVE THE BILL TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S MARINE ECOSYSTEM.
FOR CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS WERE
CLARIFYING IN NATURE. THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN AB NINE TWENTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
LEGAL NINE TWENTY FIVE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY TO PROTECTIVE ORDERS
MISTER GLORIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER A. B. NINE TWENTY FIVE
IS THAT FOR CONCURRENT SAID AND
THEN IT'S EXTENDED PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL TO ALSO APPLY TO
CIVIL HARASSER PROTECTIVE
ORDERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
GLORIA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEMS TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE
FILE ITEM THIRTY AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL READ. AS
ONLY BALL LEVIN HUNDRED BY SOME
REMEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE ACTUALLY
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLES. CONVERT
OF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AND COLLEAGUES
BEHIND ME YES ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN HUNDRED IS BACK FROM
SENATE CONCURRENCE THE
CONCURRENCE CLARIFIES THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
APPLYING TO ALL CITIES
INCLUDING CHARTER CITIES IT
ALSO MAKES TECHNICAL CLARIFYING
AND CONFORMING CHANGES AND
MAKES A NUMBER OF CHANGES TO
THE BILL'S FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MUST
COME LONGER DOES SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED VOTE.
BURKE WILL LOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX
KNOWS TWO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. PASS AND RETAIN
AND FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE FILE
ITEM THIRTY TWO AB TWELVE
THIRTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER PATTERSON
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
STANDARDIZED TESTS. MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB ONE TWO THREE FOUR
BACK ON FROM FROM THE SENATE
WITH AMENDMENTS THESE AMENDMENT
SIMPLIFIED THE BILL TO DO ONE
THING THE VERY IMPORTANT THING
IN THE BILL. TO ALLOW AC TEED
OFF FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS A
SEVENTH TEST DATE IN JULY THE
AMENDMENTS REMOVE SOME OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE BILL THAT WERE
MINOR THE BILL I RECEIVED
THIRTY NINE AND AYE VOTES NO.
NO NO VOTES RECEIVE NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY NEW ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE AB
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE BY SOME OF THE
MEMBER KANSEN CHU THAN OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE CARE
FACILITIES MR TO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWELVE THIRTY FIVES
BACK FULL CONCURRENCE THIS
AMENDMENT WERE MINOR AND
TECHNICAL. IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYE
BELOW. THANK YOU MISTER CHIU
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SIX NEW ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN BASED ON THE
NUMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACTUALLY TO GREENHOUSE GASES
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. AB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE WITH CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS IN A DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE THIS BILL
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
INVESTMENT PROGRAMS TO POST
INFORMATION ONLINE ABOUT
APPLICATION TIMELINES
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND AGENCY STAFF
CONTACTS AB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
IS RECEIVE NO NO NO VOTES AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO GO.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM THIRTY FIVE FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX AB THIRTEEN NINETY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
SIX BY SOME MEMBER OBERNOLTE
AND ACTUALLY PROTECTIVE ORDERS
MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ELDER ABUSE IS A LARGE
AND GROWING PROBLEM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BUT PARTICULARLY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA IN FACT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
REPORTED RATE OF ELDER ABUSE OF
ANY STATE IN THE COUNTRY. THIS
BILL AB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
WOULD GIVE JUDGES THE
DISCRETION TO ORDER OFFENDERS
TO CLINICAL COUNSELING OR ANGER
MANAGEMENT CLASSES WHEN ISSUING
A ELDER ABUSE RESTRAINING ORDER
AS THEY CAN ALREADY DO IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS. SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE JUDGES HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO CHOOSE WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
REFERRAL I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE IN CONCURRENCE
AND SENTIMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PASS AND RETAIN
AND FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM THIRTY NINE AB FIFTEEN
FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ. A
SOME LEGAL FIFTEEN FOURTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER PATTERSON AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY A
TELECOMMUNICATIONS DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
BUT MEADOW SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN BACK TODAY ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL MAKES A
SIMPLE CHANGE BUT A GOOD CHANGE
TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO UTILIZE
THE CALIFORNIA PHONE PHONES
PROGRAM. WITH THE PERMISSION OF
A NURSE PRACTITIONER MEMBERS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE ADDRESSED
CHAPTER OUT ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
FORTY THROUGH FORTY TWO FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE A. B. SIXTEEN
OH SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER FOR
BATH AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
CIVIL RIGHTS THIS
BOERNER HORVATH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN OH SEVEN
WILL REQUIRE CITIES AND
COUNTIES. BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO ISSUE A
NOTICE TO A BUSINESS WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT THE GENDER
TAX REPEAL ACT AT THE TIME OF
BUSINESS REVIEWS ITS BUSINESS
LICENSE AND WITH EACH RENEWAL
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
REQUIRING THE NOTICE TO BE
PROVIDED IN FOR FIVE OTHER
LANGUAGES SPANISH CHINESE
TAGALOG VIETNAMESE AND KOREAN.
LANGUAGE TO APPLY THESE
PROVISIONS TO CHARTER CITIES
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO PREPARE A
SAMPLE NOTICE TO POST ON THE
WEBSITE FOR DOWNLOAD BY CITY
AND COUNTY BUSINESS LICENSING
AGENCIES AND DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO DCA
TO PREPARE THE SAMPLE NOTICE BY
OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY.
THE BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR. THANK YOU MISS
BOERNER HORVATH SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THEMATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE I SIXTY SIX NEW ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY FAMILY MEMBER
MEDINA AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING
ARTS MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY ONE UPDATES THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE TO PROVISION
STATUTE. TO ALLOW A LICENSED
EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGIST TO ACT
AS A SUPERVISOR FOR ASSOCIATE
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
ASSOCIATE CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS AND ASSOCIATE
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS. AMENDMENTS TAKEN IS
OUR NON SUBSTANTIVE ADDING
CHAPTER NOT LANGUAGE AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY ONE AS UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I AM ASKING FOR CONCURRENCE IN
THE SENATE'S TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
STONE SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO DESIRED VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY NINE NEWS ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED. WE
WILL PASS RETAIN AND FILE I'M
FORTY SIX FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ A SOME LEGAL
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS. MR BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE ON
SENATE AMENDMENTS THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS MAKE TECHNICAL AND
MINOR CHANGES AND THAT DOUBLE
JOINTING LANGUAGE TO AVOID
CHAPTER IN PROBLEMS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB SIX
NINETY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACTUALLY THE PHARMACY DECLARING
THEIR TO SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB SIX NINETY IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE WITH PROVISIONS ADDED TO
ALLOW. A PHARMACY THAT IS
DAMAGED OR DESTROYED IN AN
EMERGENCY TO QUICKLY
REESTABLISHES ITSELF IN A NEW
LOCATION WITHOUT HAVING TO
RESTART THE FULL LICENSE
BECAUSE PROCESS AS IT WAS A
BRAND NEW PHARMACY THIS
LANGUAGE CONTAINS AN URGENCY
CLAUSE SO THAT THE POLICY WILL
BE IN PLACE FOR THIS FIRE
SEASON IN ADDITION TO THE
FELLOW CALIFORNIA C. PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL. SIX NINETY WILL
HELP THOSE VULNERABLE AND ROLL
ACCESS AREA ACCESS PHARMACY
CARE THANK YOU I ASKED FOR I
WROTE THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEN HERE NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
KNOWS THERE ON THE AMENDMENTS
THAT IN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE SB SIX THIRTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX THIRTY FIVE BY SOMETHING
NUMBER BIGELOW AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE HORSE RACING
MAKING APPROPRIATIONS THERE FOR
DECLARING EARNS EITHER UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MR
BIGELOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY FIVE
ADDRESSES A SMALL TECHNICAL
CHANGE THIS MEASURE WILL ENSURE
ALL FAIR ORDERS ARE ELIGIBLE TO
APPLY FOR THE FUNDS THROUGH
THE- THERE'S AN EXHIBITION OF
FINE CREATED BY A. B. FOURTEEN
NINETY NINE. OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. I URGE ON I'VE.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY NEWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY I SEVENTY TWO ZERO ON
THE AMENDMENTS SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS FIFTY FOUR THREE
SIXTY THREE. IN A FILE ITEM
SIXTY SIX H. R. TEN THE CLERK
WILL READ HOUSE RESOLUTION TEN
BY FAMILY MEMBER VOEPEL
RELATIVE TO MILITARY AND
VETERAN APPRECIATION MONTH. MR
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES. TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT A CHART TEN
THAT RECOGNIZES THE MONTH OF
NOVEMBER AS MILITARY AND
VETERAN APPRECIATION MONTH THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
RECOGNIZE AND THANK THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN OUR NATION TO HAVE
STOOD TO PROTECT OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVANCE OUR NATIONAL
INTEREST IN THE PRESERVE OUR
RIGHTS AND FREEDOMS. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THIRTY
TWO ACTIVE MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS AND HOME TO A
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND ACTIVE
DUTY AND RESERVE SERVICE
MEMBERS. FURTHER CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
VETERANS OF THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY MAKING OUR STATE HOME
TO THE LARGEST VETERAN
POPULATION. ALEX THESE MEN AND
WOMEN SERVE WITH SELFLESS
DEVOTION THEY PROTECT EVERYONE
IN OUR STATE IN OUR GREAT
NATION. MADAM SPEAKER MAYBE
TAKE A MOMENT OF SILENCE TO
REMEMBER THOSE WHO HAVE GIVEN
THEIR LIVES FOR THE FREEDOM OF
OUR COUNTRY. A MOMENT OF
SILENCE PLEASE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. WE'LL TAKE A MOMENT
OF SILENCE OF. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND FOR THOSE WHO
CONTINUE TO SERVE. WITH THAT
SAID COLLEAGUES AS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THE HOUSE THAT THE
FIRST ROLLED TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISS. THANK
YOU MISTER VOEPEL. SEEING AND
HEARING OTHER TODAY WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS IN THE
RESOLUTION MR APPEL. FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE THEIR SEVENTY ONE
CO AUTHORS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. A PASS IN RED. PASS
AND RETAIN AND VIOLATING SIXTY
SEVEN PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM SIXTY EIGHT PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE
THROUGH SEVENTY SIX
. PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY TWO SB THREE NINETY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY THREE
BY SENATOR STONE AND I
PLAINTIFF VESSELS. MR GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
WHILE THE LAW IS CLEAR BUT THE
RULES FOR IMPOUNDING A VEHICLE
THAT WAS USED BY SOMEONE
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE.
THE LAW IS A LOT LESS CLEAR ON
THE RULES FOR A BOAT THAT HAS
BEEN USED IN A BOATING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE ACCIDENT. SB
THREE NINETY THREE IS A MEASURE
TO ALIGN OUR WATER WAYS. BE YOU
I LAWS WITH OUR ROADWAY DO YOU
AYE LAWS. THIS BILL PASSED OUT
OF THE SENATE. UNANIMOUSLY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GARCIA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE IS ADOPTED. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE SB ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AND
ACTUALLY A DEBT COLLECTION. MR
MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THE
MINUTE SPEAKER. SB ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN CLARIFIES THE TERM
CONSUMER DEBT UNDER THE
ROSENTHAL FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES ACT INCLUDES MORTGAGE
DEBT. THERE WERE NUMEROUS CASES
WERE MORTGAGE CHARACTERS OF
HARASSING THREATEN DEBTORS
WITHOUT CLARIFICATION CONSUMERS
WITH MORTGAGE DEBT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE TREATED
UNFAIRLY. SB ONE NINETY SEVEN
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT PEOPLE WITH
MORTGAGE THAT WILL HAVE THE
SAME PROTECTIONS AS OTHER TYPES
OF DEBT. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVER. THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
SEEN HERE NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE. THE
MEASURE IS ADOPTED. AB MEMBERS
ARE GONNA GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE SB TWO NINETY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
TWO NINETY THREE BY SENATOR
SKINNER AND ACKLAND
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS THIS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
SB TWO NINETY THREE IS A
DISTRICT SPECIFIC BILL EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING LAWS
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT FOR THE CITY
VOCAL TO SUPPORT AND DEVELOP.
AROUND THE PROPOSED PRIVATELY
FINANCED STADIUM PROJECT THIS
BILL MAKES AN I FD MORE
FEASIBLE FOR OAKLAND AND
PROVIDES S. THE CITY A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE I'VE D. WHILE
ENSURING LOCALS ARE STILL
CONTROL THE PROJECT THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
OAKLAND FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL
COMMUNITY GROUPS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS LABOR AND
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WHERE X.
SEEING IN NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALENT VOTE EYES FORTY SEVEN
NO SIX. MEASURE IS. PASSES.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR GLAZER AND OTHERS AN
ACT AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT. MR
QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. YES
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS
WITH PERMISSION OF THE-
LEGISLATURE I'D LIKE TO READ
THE LETTER OF SUPPORT FOR THIS
FROM THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IS PLEASED
TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY ONE WHICH WOULD ON OR
AFTER JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
POSIT PROSPECTIVELY. BAND SALES
TAX REBATE AGREEMENTS BETWEEN A
RETAILER AND LOCAL AGENCY
INVOLVING BRADLEY BURNS SALES
AND USE TAXES IN EXCHANGE FOR
THE RETAILER LOCATING OR
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN A PLACE OF
SALE TO GENERATE AND REBATE
REVENUE FROM THE SALES OF
CHANGEABLE PROPERTY. DELIVERY
TO AND RECEIVED BY THE
PURCHASER IN THE TERRITORIAL
JURISDICTION OF ANOTHER CITY OR
COUNTY. THIS MEASURE IS
CONSISTENT WITH POLICIES
DEVELOPED BY THE LEAGUE AS PART
OF A COMPREHENSIVE MULTI YEAR
REVIEW OF ISSUES RELATED TO
COLLECTION AND DISTRIBUTION OF
SALES AND USE TAX. THE LEAGUE'S
POLICY STATES THAT SALES TAX
AGREEMENTS INVOLVING ONLINE
RETAILS SHOULD BE PROHIBITED
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THE EFFECT OF ENCOURAGING
REVENUE TO BE SHIFTED AWAY FROM
NUMEROUS COMMUNITIES AND
CONCENTRATED TO THE BENEFIT OF
ONE AGENCY WITH A PORTION THEN
REBATED TO THE RETAILER. SB
FIVE THIRTY ONE ONLY APPLIES
PROSPECTIVELY AND DOES NOT
INTERFERE WITH ANY ADJUSTING
THE EXISTING AGREEMENT OR WITH
THE ABILITY OF A LOCAL AGENCY
TO OFFER ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENTS
ACTIVES WITH ITS OWN REVENUE.
NOR DOES CHANGE THE EXISTING
ROLES FOR DETERMINING THE PLACE
FOR SALE WITH THE INCREASING
VOLUME OF INTERNET SALES A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF SALES TAX
REVENUE CAN BE CONCENTRATED IN
A RETAILER'S WAREHOUSE SALES
OFFICE OR FOR THE FITMENT
CENTER. WHICH MAKES LOCATING
THESE FACILITIES AND INTENCIóN
PROSPECT FOR LOCAL AGENCIES IN
AGREEMENT THAT BENEFITS ONE
AGENCY BY SHIFTING THE POINT OF
SALE CAN COME AT THE PHYSICAL
HARM TO MANY OTHERS. SB FIVE
THREE ONE WOULD PROHIBIT
FUTURE. EIGHT AGREEMENTS THE
RESULT IN SALES TAX REVENUE
FROM BEING SHIFTED AWAY FROM
NUMEROUS COMMUNITIES AND
CONCENTRATED TO THE BENEFIT OF
ONE AGENCY. WITH A PORTION
REBATED TO A RETAILER. MEMBERS
THIS IS ABOUT THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES ASKING US TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A RACE TO
THE BOTTOM WE DON'T HAVE ONE
AGENCY REPEATING TO A YOU
ONLINE RETAILER IN ORDER TO
TAKE REVENUE AWAY FROM OTHER
CITIES THE CITIES THEMSELVES
ARE ASKING US TO MAKE THIS
FAIR. I REQUEST YOU ARRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER. THANK YOU. MEMBERS
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL FOR SOME VERY OBVIOUS
REASONS. FRESNO AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
EXCEEDINGLY SUCCESSFUL IN BEING
COMPETITIVE AND PROVIDING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR. YEAH IMPROVED
THAT COOPERATION WITHOUT WITH
LARGE SCALE EMPLOYERS IT HAS
BEEN A SUCCESS FOR A
SIGNIFICANT PERIOD OF TIME AND
I WANT TO JUST POINT OUT THAT
OUR AREA. FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME IN A LONG TIME HAS SEEN A
SUBSTANTIAL DECREASE IN
UNEMPLOYMENT WELL BELOW DOUBLE
DIGITS. AND SO OUR MEMBERS AB
THIS REALLY I THINK IS ABOUT.
COMPETITION IT REALLY IS ABOUT
DECIDING THAT THERE ARE
COMPANIES AND WHO MAKE A DEEP
COMMITMENTS WITH RESPECT TO
HIRING AND IT DOES HELP OUT
CERTAINLY REGIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN. IN MANY INSTANCES HAVE
SICK A SIGNIFICANT A DIFFICULTY
IN ACQUIRING AND RETAINING A
REALLY GOOD A JOB CREATORS
MEMBERS DON'T TAKE AWAY A
FUNDAMENTAL. NOT HISTORIC TOOL
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
UTILIZE DOT IN MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE IN OUR AREA WHO WANT GOOD
JOBS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET THEM. SO PLEASE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
ARE VOTE NO ON THIS AND PLEASE
KEEP IN MIND THE VERY. PEOPLE
WHO ARE RIGHT NOW ENJOYING JOBS
HUGE EXPANSIONS AND QUITE
FRANKLY A HISTORIC DECLINE IN
UNEMPLOYMENT IN A REGION THAT
HAS HAD HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT FOR A
LONG TIME. WE ARE ASKED
DIVERSIFY OUR ECONOMY. THAT IS
PRECISELY WHAT THESE TOOLS
ALLOW US TO DO AND IT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY USED TO DIVERSIFY
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND FRESNO'S
ECONOMY TO THE ADVANTAGE AND
THE BENEFIT. OF HARD WORKING
PEOPLE IN THE OUR REGION WHO
WANT A JOB AND WHAT A PATHWAY.
TO HOMEOWNERSHIP AND- PLEASE
KEEP THEM IN MIND THIS IS A
TOOL THAT WE USE SUCCESSFULLY
AND CONTINUE TO SEEK TO USE IT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OUT I APPRECIATE
IT VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON MISTER EMILY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND I MUST JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE THE FORMER MAYOR OF
FRESNO AND RESPECTFULLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. AND
WHILE ALL CITIES MAY NOT BE
CREATED EQUAL WE DO COME FROM
THE FIFTH LARGEST CITY IN
CALIFORNIA AND OUR VOICE SHOULD
BE HEARD AS WELL. NOW MY MAYOR
AND LOCAL CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
HAVE ASKED ME TO STAND AND RISE
IN OPPOSITION AND IT'S OUT OF
RESPECT TO BOTH THE AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE AND TO MY
COLLEAGUE WHO'S PRESENTING IT
ON THE FLOOR. THAT I SIMPLY
READ. THEIR OPPOSITION SO THAT
WE MAY BE HEARD IN THIS
DISCUSSION. SB FIVE THIRTY ONE
WILL TAKE AWAY A VITAL TOOL FOR
THE CITY OF FRESNO AND OTHER
CITIES AROUND THE STATE THAT
HAVE USED THIS TO CREATE LOCAL
JOB GROWTH. SB FIVE THIRTY ONE
WILL ELIMINATE THE ABILITY OF
CITIES TO PROVIDE REBATES TO
BUSINESSES LOOKING TO OPEN NEW
FACILITIES WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION. IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS FRESNO HAS USED THIS
SALES TAX INCENTIVES TO ATTRACT
BUSINESSES LOOKING TO COME TO
OUR CITY THIS HAS HELPED TO
CREATE FOUR THOUSAND JOBS.
DRAMATICALLY TRANSFORMING THE
ECONOMIC SITUATION AND ONE OF
THE POOREST PARTS OF OUR STATE.
FREIGHT FRESNO'S SALES TAX
INITIATIVE IN INCENTIVE
AGREEMENTS ARE PERFORMANCE AND
JOB. CREATION BASED AND IF THE
JOBS AREN'T CREATED THE
INCENTIVES AREN'T OFFERED THE
BOTTOM LINE FOR CITIES LIKE
FRESNO IS THAT THIS TOOL IS
OFTEN TIMES THEIR ONLY OPTION
THIS BILL THE BILL STYMIED OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FRESNO
RESIDENTS A REAL OPPORTUNITY TO
GET OUT OF POVERTY. WHICH IN
TURN WILL RESULT IN NEGATIVE
ECONOMIC EFFECTS OF OUR FUTURE
INVESTMENT NOT JUST IN FRESNO
BUT FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER áREA MISTER
MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE THIRTY
ONE. I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE TYPES OF
INCENTIVE AGREEMENTS BUT THIS
BILL GOES TOO FAR. WHAT WE NEED
pACCOUNTABILITY IN THESE
AGREEMENTS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING LOCAL JOBS A
LOCAL BENEFITS. ALTHOUGH THIS
BILL DOESN'T MAKE CHANGES TO
THE DISTRIBUTION OF REVENUES
FROM THESE AGREEMENTS THE
AUTHOR HAS BEEN OPEN ABOUT HIS
DESIRE TO SHIFT YOU COMMERCE
REVENUE FROM THE PLACE OF
DISTRIBUTION TO THE PLACE OF
DELIVERY. WITH SEVERAL
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS IN MY
DISTRICT SUCH A CHANGE WOULD BE
DEVASTATING TO LOCAL BUDGETS.
TAKEN AWAY REVENUES FROM THE
COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES WERE
DOING THE LABOR TO GET ONLINE
GOODS DISTRIBUTED. ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PARIS THAT I
REPRESENT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE ON SB FIVE THIRTY
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
MISS REST YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF ELSE BE FIVE
THIRTY ONE. AS WE KNOW THE FOR
RIGHT THE RETAILER HAS ONE
LOCATION OF THE STATE. THAT
LOCATION IS DETERMINED TO BE
THE PLACE OF SALE. IF THE
RETAILER HAS NO SALES A RETAIL
LOCATIONS IN THE STATE WHAT
HOUSING FULFILLMENT OPERATION
WITHIN THE STATE THE PLACE OF
SALE IS DETERMINED TO BE WHERE
THE ORDER IS SHIPPED FROM. THE
INLAND EMPIRE INCLUDING THE
REGION IN SANDRA DINO COUNTY
HAS BECOME HOME TO A LARGE
NUMBER OF FULFILLMENT CENTERS
AND WAREHOUSES FOR ONLINE
RETAILERS. MY OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE DOES NOT MEAN THAT
I WANT MORE WAREHOUSES OR MORE
FULFILLMENT CENTERS IN MY
COMMUNITY. BECAUSE MANY OF
THESE BRING ADVERSE AFFECTS TO
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH OF OUR RESIDENTS. BUT I
ALSO WILL NOT ACCEPT THE TAKING
AWAY OF THOSE INCENTIVES GIVEN
OR TO BE GIVEN IN THE FUTURE.
THE IMPACTS TO EXISTING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENTS
AS WELL AS IMPACTS TO
AGREEMENTS CURRENTLY IN
NEGOTIATIONS A FUTURE
DEVELOPMENTS WILL BE ADVERSELY
AFFECTED BY THIS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON SB FIVE THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
MISS REYES MISTER GRAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN OPPOSING THIS
MEASURE FORCE THEY MEMBERS AND
WOULD LIKE TO POSE A QUESTION.
TO THE BODY. WHEN WE WELL WHEN
I ARRIVED HERE IN TWENTY TWELVE
NEWLY ELECTED WE WERE ON THE
HEELS OF HAVING A LIMITED
REDEVELOPMENT IN THE STATE AS A
TOOL FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
ENGAGE IN ACTIVITIES TO GROW
THE ECONOMY FIVE JOBS
PARTICULARLY IN PORTIONS OF THE
STATE LIKE THE SOUNDS ABOUT
LIKE MY DISTRICT WHERE WE STILL
STRUGGLE EVEN AT THE HEIGHT OF
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WITH HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES AND RATES OF
POVERTY THAT ARE FAR TOO HIGH.
AND WE DISCUSSED DOING
SOMETHING TO GIVE LOCAL
CHURCHES BACK SOME TOOLS AND
WE'VE DISCUSSED IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN OUR TWENTY
NINETEEN NOT TWENTY TWELVE WE
STILL HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING TO
DEAL WITH THE FALLOUT FROM
REDEVELOPMENT HERE I FIND ARE.
ANOTHER TOOL. LIVING ELIMINATED
AND I THINK IT'S JUST A GOOD
MOMENT FOR THE BODY TO POTS AND
TO ASK OURSELVES WHAT ACTIONS
ARE WE ARE WE CAN ENGAGE IN A
DISCUSSION. TO REVITALIZE THE
USERS STATE AND FINE IF THIS
ISN'T THE RIGHT TOOL HERE. IF
REDEVELOPMENT WASN'T THE RIGHT
TOOL THEN WHAT ARE THE RIGHT
TOOLS AND HOW CAN WE ENGAGE IN
THAT CONVERSATION ACTUALLY GET
SOMETHING DONE FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA SO. TODAY THIS IS
NOT. THE PATH FORWARD AND I
RICHARD NO VOTE. ON SB FIVE TO
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GRAHAM IS OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT. OF
SB FIVE THIRTY ONE AND I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL
TAKE A STEP BACK. AND THINK
ABOUT OUR RESPONSIBILITY. TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS NOT JUST IN
THE REGIONS THAT WE COME FROM
BUT IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE POLICY. OF
HAVING DIFFERENT CITIES COMPETE
WITH EACH OTHER TO SEE HOW MUCH
TAX REVENUE THEY CAN GIVE A WAY
TO LOWER A COMPANY. TO LOCATE.
A FULFILLMENT CENTER IN THEIR
CITY IS NOT A GOOD ONE IT'S NOT
A GOOD ONE. FOR CALIFORNIA AS A
WHOLEAND ALTHOUGH IT MIGHT BE
GOOD FOR THAT PARTICULAR CITY
IF THEY GET THAT FULFILLMENT
CENTER. IT'S NOT GOOD FOR ALL
OF OUR CITIES PUT TOGETHER AND
I SAY THAT AS SOMEONE
REPRESENTING AN AREA OF THE
STATE. THAT ACTUALLY DOES
BETTER THAN NOT UNDER THE
CURRENT POLICY SO YOU KNOW THAT
MY THOUGHTS ARE SINCERE. BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE TAKE A LOOK AS A BODY.
AT THIS ENTIRE POLICY OF HOUSE
SALES TAX REVENUE ON ON LINE
SALES IS DISTRIBUTED. YEAH I'M
REALLY HOPEFUL THAT NEXT YEAR
WE WILL SIT DOWN AND HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION BECAUSE IT IS NOT.
SORT OF GOING TO A STORE THAT
THE SALES TAX REVENUE FROM THAT
SALE GOES TO A CITY OTHER THE
NEEDLES BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN
NEEDLES. THERE DEPENDING ON AT
THAT REVENUE TO PAVE THE
STREETS AND A POLICE THE
COMMUNITY AND WE'RE TAKING THAT
REVENUE AWAY FROM THEM. SO I
THINK THAT WE REALLY AS A STATE
NEED TO LOOK AT THE ENTIRE
POLICY. OF WHERE THE NEXUS OF
THOSE SALES ARE BECAUSE I THINK
IT OUGHT TO BE CLEARLY. THE I.
LOCATION OF WHERE THOSE GOODS
ARE SHIPPED TO NOT WEAR THOSE
GOODS ARE SHIPPED FROM. BUT IN
THE MEANTIME AT THIS CLOSES A
OF VERY ON HOLD THE ON HEALTHY
LOOPHOLE. AND I REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE. YES I WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBER FROM BIG
BEAR FOR SUPPORT. A MEMBERS YOU
CAN SEE THAT WERE SPLIT HERE
NOT LONG. PARTY LINES BUT ALONG
THE PHILOSOPHY LINES. FIRST OF
ALL THESE JOBS THAT ARE
HAPPENING THAT PEOPLE ARE
RIGHTLY PROUD OF AND YOU'RE
GLAD TO HAVE. VISUAL WAREHOUSE
JOBS THE WAREHOUSES ARE THERE
SO THEY CAN DELIVER THE
WAREHOUSES WOULD BE IN THE
GENERAL VICINITY OF THE CITY'S
REGARDLESS. BUT WHAT WE CAN
HAVE IS CITIES COMPETING
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER TO GIVE
MORE MONEY TO THE CORPORATION
SO THERE IS LESS MONEY TO FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY THERE'S LESS
MONEY FOR FIRE THERE'S LESS
MONEY FOR POLICE. THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES. AND THE LABOR MOVEMENT.
ARE VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THESE
BILLS. BECAUSE FRANKLY THOSE
JOBS ARE GOING TO BE IN YOUR
CITIES REGARDLESS. BUT YOU'RE
GONNA GET YOUR TAX REVENUE AND
BY THE WAY THIS DOES NOTHING IF
YOU HAVE AN AGREEMENT ALREADY
DOES NOT TOUCH THAT IT DOES NOT
TOUCH ANYTHING IN THE WAY THE
REVENUE IT IS COUNTED IT'LL
STILL GO TO THE WAREHOUSE. IN
THESE WAREHOUSES AGAIN. IF THEY
THEY WOULD BE IN YOUR GENERAL
VICINITY BECAUSE THEY'RE THERE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
DELIVER. SO YOU'LL GET THESE
JOBS ANYWAY. YOU WON'T TAKE
AWAY FUNDING FOR POLICE FIRE
AND OTHER ESSENTIAL SERVICES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
QUIRK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS ORDER. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. SQUIRES
FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. MEMBERS THIRTY
DESIRE TO VOTE. I CAN'T.
CALDERON IS A COP. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REVISING MY PREVIOUS RE REFER
ALL OF ITEM FORTY AB FIFTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE LOW TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. TO ALSO
INCLUDE THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. MOVING
TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY
NINE THROUGH ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR WILL
BE PASSED ENTERTAINED DOES ANY
MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY
MISTAKE CLAIMS MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE UP TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. QUIRK WILL
OPEN THE ROMAN CALENDAR. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ.
YEAH I SIXTEEN IS THERE ON THE
URGENCY AND I SIXTY THREE NO
THERE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
YOU CAN THANK COUNTERS ADOPTED
THE CLERK WILL READ THEIR
MEETING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SOMETHING CURRENT
VERSION ONE OH NINE I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO IT'S ONLY
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY ONE AYE
SIXTY THREE NOCERA'S ANNIKA
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY TWO I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS THERE'S ONLY
CURRENT VERSION ONE THIRTY ONE
I SIXTY THREE KNOWS HEROES N
THE CURB RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
THREE. I SIXTY THREE KNOWS
THEIR RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY TWO
I SIXTY THREE NO THERE ARE
MAKING CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY THREE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO IS ONLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY FOUR I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO AS ON THE
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY FIVE I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS THEIR HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY EIGHT I SIXTY
THREE NEWS. HOUSE RESOLUTION
FORTY FOUR I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL FIVE OH SEVEN
AYE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
BILL SIX OH ONE I SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY I SIXTY THREE NOTE AND
SENATE. CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY FOUR BY SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO. MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS MONDAY SEPTEMBER SECOND
IS A HOLIDAY. LABOR DAY TUESDAY
SEPTEMBER THIRD IS FLOOR
SESSION AND ONE PM. DOTSON.
YEAH CAT WOMAN
. MEMBERS WE WILL
ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGES AT THIS
TIME. MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU SB TWO
NINETY THREE I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY THREE I TO NOT VOTING.
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
AND VIOLATING EIGHTY SEVEN SB
FIVE THIRTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLOSE WILL
RESULT. MR QUICKNESS
RECONSIDERATION CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES. I THIRTY
FIVE MINUTES TWENTY ONE. WHAT
WAS THAT MEASURE FAILS MISTER
QUIRK NOTICES RECONSIDERATION.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED WE WILL
NOW MOVES THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. WARM CALL IS LIFTED.
THANK YOU. FOLLOWING MEMBERS
ARE GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MISTER RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THEN
TODAY I RISE IN THE MEMORY OF
MY DEAR FRIEND JOHN MCKINLEY
FUDGE JUNIOR. WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SUMMER DEAL
AND DOUBLE ACP. JOHN WAS BORN
ON JUNE FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
FIFTY AND MERCED TO AN AIRFORCE
FAMILY BEFORE MOVING TO THE
INLAND EMPIRE. HE WAS A
LIFELONG PUBLIC SERVANT AND
FAMILY MAN HE STARTED SERVING
HIS COUNTRY AT THE EARLY AGE OF
SEVENTEEN WHEN HE MOVED TO
WASHINGTON DC WORKING FOR THE
FBI AS A FINGERPRINT EXAMINER.
AFTER A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME HE
JOINED THE METRO DC POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN WASHINGTON DC.
AND HELP TO ENSURE PUBLIC
SAFETY FOLLOWING THE PEAK OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
RETIRING FROM THE POLICE FORCE
DUE TO AN INJURY HE MOVED BACK
TO CALIFORNIA AND ATTENDED CAL
STATE SAN BERNARDINO. WHERE HE
EARNED HIS BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE AND HIS
MASTER'S DEGREE IN SOCIAL
SCIENCE. JOHN WAS ALSO
INSTRUMENTAL IN PROVIDING A
PLATFORM FOR NATIVE AMERICAN
EDUCATORS ARTISTS AND
PERFORMERS AND PLAYED A VITAL
ROLE IN BRINGING SALMON WELLS
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
CHILDREN'S PROGRAM TO THE
UNIVERSITY WERE OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS HAVE PROTECT
IN THAT IN THAT EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE. HE SERVED ON THE
SALMON IN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT BOARD OF TRUSTEES. AND
STATE AND STARTED THE FRIENDS
OF JOHN FUDGE TEXTBOOK
SCHOLARSHIP IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN TO HELP PROVIDE
SCHOLARSHIPS. WELL I SERVED ON
THE SEMINAL COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS JOHN WORKED AS A
FIELD REPRESENTATIVE AND LATER
BECAME MY CHIEF OF STAFF. HE
PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST ELEVENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN AND IS SURVIVED
BY HIS BROTHERS TERRY AND STAND
FUTCH THIS SISTER LOIS AND SON
MARKETS FUDGE JUNIOR. TODAY I
RISE AND ASKS FOR THE MEMORY OF
MY FRIEND JOHN FUTCH. WHO IS
NOT ONLY. SOMEONE WE WORK
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY BUT A DEAR
CLOSE FRIEND OF MINE. I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF MY FRIEND JOHN MCKINLEY
FUTCH JUNIOR. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER OMINOUS MISS RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS TO
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. TODAY I RISE
TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HIGHLAND. AND ALSO WE DURING
THE MEMORY OF A LEADER IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHO DEDICATED HIS
ENTIRE LIFE. FOR THE BENEFIT OF
ALL. JOHN FOUGHT TO JUNIOR
IMPARTED ON ALL OF US A DUTY TO
PARTICIPATE ADVOCATE AND TO
COMMUNICATE. WE HONOR HIS
LEGACY OF SERVING OTHERS AND
BEING OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
KEEPER. AT CAL STATE SAN
BERNARDINO HE EARNED HIS
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND CONTINUE TO ON TO
EARN HIS MASTER'S DEGREE IN
SOCIAL SCIENCES. JOHN CONTINUED
WITH HIS PASSION FOR EDUCATION
AS AN ADMINISTRATOR AT CAL
STATE SAN BERNARDINO CORPS HE
DEDICATED HIS WORK TO HONORING
CULTURE AND DIVERSITY. AS A
SAMBAR DINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TRUSTEE HE HELP
PROVIDE SCHOLARSHIPS FOR
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY FOR FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS AND THOSE WITH
COMMUNITY SERVICE INVOLVEMENT.
JOHN WAS DEDICATED TO HELPING
OTHERS AND PURSUED VARIOUS EVAN
AVENUES OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
AWARENESS AND ADVOCACY. JOHN
TREATED EVERYONE WITH RESPECT
NO MATTER THEIR PERCEIVED
POSITION IN SOCIETY. MAYA
ANGELOU SAID THAT PEOPLE WILL
FORGET WHAT YOU SAID. WE WILL
FORGET WHAT YOU DID BUT PEOPLE
WILL NEVER FORGET HOW YOU MADE
THEM FEEL. JOHN WAS MY FRIEND
AND A FRIEND TO THE COMMUNITY
THAT FOUND ITSELF MARGINALIZED
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND LEFT
BEHIND. JOHN NOW LEAVES A
LEGACY OF SELFLESSNESS SERVICE
AND SACRIFICE WHICH WILL BE
LIVED ON THROUGH HIS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HIGHLANDER
RESPECTFULLY AUS THE WE'D TURN
IN THE MEMORY OF JOHN M. FUDGE
JUNIOR. THANK YOU MISTER S.
MISS GONZALES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK
THAT WE HAD TURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF AUGUSTINE GAS CHAVEZ
A CHICANO ACTIVIST IN THE
FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY'S OFFICE OF
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAMS AND ETHNIC AFFAIRS.
THAT'S CHAVEZ WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN FORTY THREE AND SONORA
TEXAS ONE OF SEVEN CHILDREN IN
A ONE BEDROOM HOME. HE
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL JOIN
THE U. S. NAVY AND SERVED AS A
HOSPITAL CORPSMAN FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO TO NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX AT NAVAL MEDICAL
CENTER SAN DIEGO. AFTER LEAVING
THE NAVY HE ATTENDED SAN DIEGO
CITY COLLEGE AND THEN
TRANSFERRED TO WHAT WAS THEN
SAN DIEGO STATE COLLEGE WHERE
HE GRADUATED WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN POLITICAL SCIENCE. HE
WAS APPOINTED DIRECTOR STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES UPON HIS
GRADUATION. STRONGLY DEDICATED
TO SOCIAL AND EDUCATIONAL
JUSTICE IN EQUITY AND EQUALITY
THAT'S WAS THE ARCHITECT OF THE
CURRENT OFFICE OF EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS AND ETHNIC
AFFAIRS. IN HELP CREATE WHAT IS
NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF CHICANO
AND CHICANA STUDIES. AS HE
MENTORED INSPIRED COUNTLESS
STUDENTS HE ALSO ESTABLISHED
EXTENSIVE COLLECTION OF CHICANO
AND CHICANA RELATED HISTORICAL
MATERIALS HOUSED IN THE LEVEL
LIBRARY. HE SERVED IN A NUMBER
OF PROFESSIONAL COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING MATCHA
SAID RATHER SAN DIEGO COUNTY
THE BROWN BERETS OF SAN DIEGO
AND THE AMERICAN GI FORUM.
THAT'S WAS THE LEAD CO FOUNDER
AND ORGANIZER OF THE DEFEND THE
HONOR CAMPAIGN AN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PRESERVING AND
KNOWLEDGE IN THE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF LATINO AND LATINA VETERANS
WHO SERVED IN WORLD WAR TWO
KOREA AND VIETNAM. BY
ADVOCATING FOR THE INCLUSION OF
THEIR MILITARY EXPERIENCES IN
CIVIL RIGHTS STRUGGLES IN
DOCUMENT TREES BOOKS IN SCHOOL
CURRICULA. HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE THREE SONS HIS
DAUGHTER AND FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN. MEMBERS ASSET WE
DURING IN THE MEMORY OF A
LEADER IN OUR SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY AND A PERSONAL HERO
OF MINE. MR DESKTOP AS- THANK
YOU MISS GONZALES. CAREER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
HONOR THE MEMORY OF STEFANO
PEOPLE ONLY A DEDICATED
COMMUNITY MEMBER AND WINE MAKER
WHO PASSED AWAY ON JULY THIRD
HE WAS NINETY SEVEN YEARS OLD.
MR RIVOLI WAS BORN AND LIVED IN
LOS ANGELES UNTIL HIS PARENTS
DECIDED TO MOVE BACK TO ITALY
IN NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR WHEN HE
WAS ONLY THREE YEARS OLD AT
SIXTEEN MISERABLE RETURNED TO
LOS ANGELES TO WORK AT THE SAN
ANTONIO WINERY IN LINCOLN
HEIGHTS IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE THAT HIS UNCLE SANTA
COME BEYOND GAME. CAN BE ANY CO
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTEEN.
RIGALI MET AND MARRIED MOTHER
LANA HIS WIFE IN NINETEEN FORTY
SIX. THE TWO SHARED A PASSION
FOR WINE MAKING AND WORKED AS A
TEAM. TO GROW AND DEVELOP THE
WINERY AND TO LOG INTO A LOS
ANGELES MAINSTAY. MR A BULLY
AND HIS WIFE RAISE THREE
CHILDREN. WHO CONTINUE TO WORK
AT THE WINERY. THIS FAMILY
DYNAMIC AND THE ENTHUSIASM I
MISSED ROBLEY SHOWED FOR THAT
HE SHOWED FOR HIS TRADE MADE
THE WINERY IN A SUCCESS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN JUST LAST
YEAR THE SAN ANTONIO WINERY WAS
NAMED THE AMERICAN WINERY. OF
THE YEAR. BY WINE ENTHUSIAST
MAGAZINE. MR OF ALL THESE
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT TO
THE WINERY WILL CONTINUE TO
LIVE ON. PROVIDING A FAMILY
EXPERIENCE AND A GREAT WIND TO
DRINK FOR ALL. MISS REBEL IS
SURVIVED BY HIS THREE CHILDREN
SOUND THOUGH KATIE AND STEVE.
TEN GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVEN
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND I AFTER WE
ADJOURN AND HAS MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISS CAREER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR SECOND
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF CUDDLE SAT ACOSTA. A
MUSICIAN ARTIST AND LABOR
ACTIVIST WHO WAS KILLED ON JULY
TWENTY FIFTH BY A FAMILY MEMBER
IN A TRAGIC COMBINATION. OF GUN
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. HIS
FATHER GOT LOW SAT ACOSTA
SENIOR WAS ALSO KILLED. CHARLES
WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF HIS
COMMUNITY AND BECAME A STUDENT
ACTIVISTS. FOCUSED ON LABOR AND
HUMAN RIGHTS DURING HIS TIME AT
UCLA. CALLERS TURNED HIS
PASSION FOR LABOR RIGHTS INTO A
CAREER POST GRADUATION BY
BECOMING A FIELD ORGANIZER FOR
SEIU LOCAL NINETY NINE. IN THIS
POSITION CARLOS HELP CAMPAIGN
FOR THE FIFTEEN DOLLAR AN HOUR
MINIMUM WAGE FOR LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WORKERS. HE LATER WENT ON TO
WORK FOR SEIU. YOU H. W.
OUTSIDE OF HIS WORK CARLOS
BROUGHT MUSIC AN ARTIST
COMMUNITY HE WAS A FOUNDING
MEMBER. AND THE BASS PLAYER OF
LUCK TOMBA ONE OF MY FAVORITE
BANDS A COMBAT STYLE MUSIC
GROUP BASED OUT OF LOS ANGELES
CARLOS WAS ALSO A MEMBER OF LAW
MEENA. IN CITY TERRACE ALSO IN
EIGHTY FIFTY ONE AN ARTIST
COLLECTIVE THAT FOCUS ON
ADVANCING CIVIL RIGHTS AND
COMMUNITY AWARENESS THROUGH ART.
WHETHER WITH HIS COLLEAGUES HIS
BANDMATES OR HIS FELLOW
ARTISTS. CARLOS WAS OPTIMISTIC
AND A SOURCE OF JOY FOR MANY.
HIS PASSING HAS NOT DIMMED THE
LIGHT HE BROUGHT TO OTHERS. BUT
RATHER ENCOURAGED THE
COMMUNITIES HE WAS A PART OF TO
EMBRACE HIS POSITIVITY. AND
INCLUSIVITY AND HAS ABSENCE.
CARLOS LEGACY WILL LIVE ON
THROUGH THE MUSIC HE WROTE THE
ART HE CREATED. THE ENERGY HIS
BIRD WITHIN THE LABOR COMMUNITY
AND HE WAS ONLY THIRTY THREE
YEARS OLD. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
AND I ASK THAT WE IN TURN IN
HIS MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR THIRTY GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
HONOR THE MEMORY OF ONE THE US
AN OFFICER WITH THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT. WHO LEFT
THIS GOOD EARTH AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY FOUR. THE LOSS OF AN
OFFICER IS ALWAYS TRAGIC BUT
OFFICER DS IS PARTICULARLY
HEARTBREAKING TO THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY AND TO ME IN
PARTICULAR. TWENTIETH WAS
RAISED IN. THE NORTHEAST LA
COMMUNITY AND RECITED IN
CYPRESS PARK AND EIGHTY FIFTY
ONE. SINCE THE AGE OF FIVE HE
WANTED TO BE A POLICE OFFICER.
OFFICER DS STUCK WITH THAT
VISION AND WORK HARD TO BECOME
A MEMBER OF THE FORCE BY THE
YOUNG AGE OF TWENTY TWO. THE
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT
OFFICER DS. HAD PAIRED WITH HIS
COMPASSION AND ABILITY TO SEE
THE GOOD IN ALL OF THOSE AROUND
HIM MADE HIM A GREAT POLICE
OFFICER. OFFICER DIAZ WAS ABLE
TO MAKE CONNECTIONS WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND LEFT THE POSITIVE
A LASTING IMPRESSION ON THOSE
HE INTERACTED WITH. HE WAS A
SHINING EXAMPLE OF A COMMUNITY
POLICE OFFICER. USING HIS
POSITION TO IMPROVE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD HE GREW UP IN. ON
JULY TWENTY SEVEN OFFICER TIAS
WAS SHOT AND KILLED WHILE OFF
DUTY. AS HE AND HIS GIRLFRIEND
AND HER BROTHERS FOR GRABBING A
BITE TO EAT AT A VERY POPULAR
TACO STAND IN LINCOLN HEIGHTS.
OFFICER DS ATTEMPTED TO STOP AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS TAG IN A
WALL. AND WAS GUNNED DOWN. ALL
OFFICER TIAS WANTED TO DO WAS
BETTER OUR COMMUNITY. HIS
ACTIONS MUST NOT BE FORGOTTEN
AND SHOULD BE LOOKED AT AND HE
SHOULD BE LOOKED AT AS A MODEL
FOR TEACHING YOUNG OFFICERS THE
DEDICATION AND HUMILITY NEEDED
TO SUCCEED. AND SUPPORT OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND I ASKED WE
ENTERED IN HIS MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO. MR
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN A MEMORY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I RISE TO ENSURE
AN IN MEMORY OF CANEY ARNOLD OF
HARBOUR CITY. CAN ARNOLD WAS A
FIGHTER FOR THE HARBOUR CITY
COMMUNITY. AFTER WORKING FOR
OVER THIRTY TWO YEARS FOR THE
US DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE. HE
SERVED ON THE HARBOUR CITY
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL. KENNY
ARNOLD WAS A FIGHTER WHO IS NOT
AFRAID TO CHALLENGE THE STATUS
QUO. HE RAN AGAINST AN
INCUMBENT. FOR A LOS ANGELES
CITY COUNCIL SEAT. AND LATER HE
RAN AGAINST ME FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
BECAUSE HE WAS SUCH A FIGHTER I
WAS SHOCKED AND SADDENED TO
HEAR THAT HE RECENTLY PASSED
AWAY. HIS MEMORY AND HIS LEGACY
WILL LIVE ON. THROUGH HIS WIFE
LORI THIS FAMILY. MANY FRIENDS.
AND WITH RESPECT AND MY DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY I ASK
THAT THE ASSEMBLY A JOINT IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAME SUGGESTS WE PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO
JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WE PASS RETAINED ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MR BREAUX
MOVES AND MISTER COOLEY SECONDS
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL TUESDAY SEPTEMBER THIRD
AT ONE PM